[Music]
nearly two years into the Trump
presidency the man who made the phrase
you're fired famous has already sent
five cabinet members packing that number
could grow as question surround the
futures of interior secretary Ryan's
inky and most recently homeland security
secretary Kirsten Nielsen and tonight's
whatever happened to segment my
colleague Bret bear looks at the
president's relationships with other
cabinet members whose careers in
Washington came to a sudden end to see
whether the writing may be on the wall
President Donald Trump is hinting of
changes to come I'm very happy with
almost all of my cabinet before he was
president mr. Trump vowed he would fill
his cabinet with top notch nominees the
cabinet we're gonna have all the best
people we're gonna find out who they are
it turns out some did not have the best
judgment
some of the president's cabinet members
are opting not to fly with the Public
Health and Human Services Secretary Tom
Price became the cabinet's first
casualty
the former Georgia congressman and
doctor came into the administration with
hopes of helping Congress to repeal and
replace Obamacare fixing this situation
as the saying goes requires an act of
Congress but in mid-september a report
surfaced that the secretary had used
private jets for official business at
least 26 times at a cost of more than
400,000 taxpayer dollars
amid the uproar including that of
President Trump secretary Price told me
he would repay his debt to taxpayers and
you say in the statement the taxpayers
won't pay a dime from my seat on those
plans but you're writing a check for we
understand from your officials fifty one
thousand eight hundred eighty seven
dollars the total cost is estimated at
more than 400,000 for the 26 flights
since May is that okay well as I said
there's an ongoing review being done by
the Inspector General I think it's
important that we wait for that but the
very next day after less than 10 months
on the job price resigned saying he did
not want to be a distraction to the work
of HHS Environmental Protection Agency
administrator Scott Pruett had a
promising start but his spending habits
also got in the way of the agenda I
recognize there have been very troubling
media reports Pruett faced months of
scrutiny over reports of lavish spending
and suspected ethics violations
everything from pricey round-the-clock
security to spending forty three
thousand dollars on a soundproof phone
booth and even reports that he asked
donors for help in landing a job for his
wife
on the 4th of July Pruitt was spotted
attending celebrations at the White
House one day later he resigned from the
administration of that ovide Avery will
never have to use those words in our
David David Chokin was the only holdover
from the Obama administration and his
appointment as Secretary of Veterans
Affairs in February of 2017 seemed to
hold great promise for the troubled
agency a practicing dr. Shulkin would
sometimes meet with patients at VA
medical centers and vowed to turn the
agency around we're beginning to finally
deal with the issues that have plagued
the VA system for decades
Shogun's position and the administration
came under scrutiny following an
Inspector General report that found he
improperly accepted wimbledon tickets
and airfare for his wife during a
european trip that cost taxpayers more
than 122 thousand dollars I do regret
the decisions that have been made that
have taken the focus off of that
important work regrets
we're not enough this was used in a
political way to try to remove me and
you know this is Washington I'm a big
I'm a big boy I understand that
administration downfalls were not
limited to ethics probes others felt the
president's wrath when they opposed him
I can say this is a man that's respected
all over the world before he even begins
Rex Tillerson was a very unlikely
candidate for Secretary of State a CEO
of a massive company with little
experience in politics but one who had
the complete support of President Trump
at the beginning but the two soon
publicly clashed over several Foreign
Affairs items notably the Iran nuclear
deal Rex and I have been talking about
this for a long time what do you look at
the Iran deal I think it's terrible I
guess he fit it was okay and North Korea
with the president tweeting in October
of 2017 that Tillerson was quote wasting
his time trying to negotiate with little
Rocketman but perhaps most notably there
was what became known as the [ __ ]
moment
main headline of the story that you
called the president of [ __ ] the places
I come from we don't deal with that kind
of petty nonsense and it is intended to
know nothing but divide people and I'm
just not going to be part of this effort
to divide this administration rumors of
Tillerson demise began last November but
President Trump did not dump his top
diplomat until March my commission his
Secretary of State will terminate at
midnight watch the 31st Tillison would
leave his job just four hundred five
days after becoming Secretary of State
one of the shortest tenures in modern
history then Senator Jeff Sessions was
one of Donald Trump's most ardent and
earliest supporters on the campaign
trail soon after he was elected
president Trump made the former Alabama
Senator his Attorney General it is with
great pride very great pride that I say
these words to you right now
Attorney General Jeff Sessions what
session seemed to quickly fall from
favor after choosing to recuse himself
from the Russia investigation and I am
disappointed in the Attorney General he
should not have recused himself
president Trump publicly lambasted
sessions on social media again and again
despite the discord sessions remained
mostly mom about it as he remained on
the job how's your relationship with
President Trump now a little rocky there
for one well we had the president's very
clear about when he's happy with
somebody when he's not happy for
somebody but President Trump kept the
heat on his Attorney General saying he
would have liked a do-over on his AG
pick jeff Sessions never took control of
the Justice Department questions about
his future went on for months President
Trump says he will not fire his Attorney
General Jeff Sessions before the
November midterm elections but after
that the president would not commit
finally one day after the midterms the
president officially asked sessions for
his resignation now
the question is who's next from
Washington Bret Baier Fox News